We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I got a voicemail from a caller who is really,
really mad at me.
The caller, of course, is listening to the
show in the background, which is almost a
requirement for some of these angry phone
calls.
And they claim I am lying.
Lots of people voted while dead, lots of dead
voters, and they're just really upset with
me.
Take a listen to this.
And to hear that, I'm not sure if be watching
on television.
The facts are absolutely bizarre and saying
that people don't vote.
I have two friends that have already pulled
out.
The first of all, in a literal sense, dead
people don't vote.
Obviously, that's not what we're talking about,
is false votes being cast for dead people,
but dead people.
How is it a fact that dead people vote if
they're dead, they can't vote or they had
a notary sign the affidavit?
They did.
Their grandmother has been dead for years
and she voted and several other people.
So you're lying to the public on television?
I don't you know, I don't watch this program,
but that makes me think you're either a puppet,
right.
Or interested in just false narrative.
Right.
But either way, I don't know how much it allows
me to rely on television like this.
So sad.
Anyway, I expected better or worse, I should.
And some of these people on television like
this like this program.
Right.
I'm more interested than reality.
Truth will always have people free anyway.
That's what I have to say.
I just was watching and I thought this was
a very strange statement to make and there
were definitely legal actions going on.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, so so we have to understand
this is kind of how they get you.
They Gish Gallop you and they say.
Listen, there's there's affidavit this is
exactly what the Trump campaign did, Kayleigh
McEnany, holding up all of these affidavits,
affidavits aren't actual proof of anything.
And when you the way to analyze claims of
supposedly dead people voting is you do what
the BBC did.
And the BBC started with the claim in Michigan
of 10000 dead voters.
They took a sample.
They figured out a bunch of those people are
alive, a bunch of those people, there's no
reason to think they are dead.
Some of the dead people voting were were sons
voting and the votes due to clerical errors
being credited to their fathers.
You know, when someone says, my friend is
an affidavit about his grandmother voting,
we don't know anything about it.
It's an anecdotal claim about one vote and
even if true, would be meaningless in the
broader context of the election.
But we've got to be really careful, guys.
We can't fall for this stuff.
And there's a lot of people out there that
that depend on you falling for baseless lies.
And we've all got to protect ourselves from
that.
We have a great bonus show.
We will talk about which recounts will happen
and which ones will or will not.
We will talk about Speaker Pelosi, round two
and also the fiasco happening in South Dakota
with their Republican governor and coronavirus.
Those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Grab a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom and
I will see you then.